THANKS, GOVERNOR.
HARASSED BY LEFTIST.
IN TULSA A MAN FOUND A HATEFUL
THE PERSON KEPT RETURNING AND HE
CONFRONTED HER WITH A CAMERA.
HE JOINED US TO GIVE US THE
WHOLE STORY.
THIS IS LIKE YOU ARE NOW
CONSIDERED BRAVE BECAUSE YOU
SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP AND DON'T
HIDE IT.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I AM A VERY LOUD TRUMP
SUPPORTENER MY NEIGHBORHOOD.
THERE WERE BERNIE SANDERS AND
HILLARY CLINTON POSTERS
WELL, SHE DIDN'T LIKE THAT.
I GOT HATEFUL NOTES.
>> Laura: THREATENING OR YOU ARE
JUST A RACIST?
>> LIKE I AM A RACIST.
I COULD NOT FIGURE OUT WHO IT
WAS.
I GOT A CAMERA AND CAUGHT HER ON
TAPE.
>> Laura: YOUR WIFE IS INDIAN
AND THEY SAID YOU HATED DARK
SKIN PEOPLE.
I HAVE ADOPTED KID AND ONE IS
LAUGH.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE YOU BROUGHT
INTO YOUR HOUSE THAT NEEDED
HELP?
>> IT'S FUNNY HOW THEY ASSUME
BECAUSE I AM A TRUMP SUPPORTER
THEY ASSUME I AM A RACIST AND
DON'T LIKE WOMEN.
THEIR MINDS:
SO WIMPY.
YOU SEE THESE BACK-BACK WEARING
ADULT MEN WITH BACKWARD BASEBALL
CAPS.
MOST OF THE CONSERVATIVE WOMEN
COULD BEAT THEM IN ARM
WRESTLING.
THEY COULD SETTLE IT THAT WAY.
THIS IS YOUR GENERATION.
ARE YOU 30 YEARS OLD?
>> 28.
>> Laura: HOW DOES THIS MAKE YOU
FEEL ABOUT YOUR GENERATION?
>> DISAPPOINTING.
ALL OF MY LIFE I AM USED TO SEE
HOW ADULTS LIVE AND NOT HOW
CHILDREN LIVE.
I DON'T WANT TO GO BACK AND SEE
WHERE THIS GENERATION GREW UP
FROM.
IT WOULD PROBABLY MAKE ME SICK.
>> Laura: THEY ARE ALL ACTING
LIKE THEY ARE STILL IN A
FRATERNITY IN COLLEGE TO VENT
ABOUT HOW ROTTEN AMERICA IS.
I LOVE BRINGING IN JUST REGULAR